[Musik]
ich bin seit 29 jahren polizeireporter
ich berichte über brutale verbrechen
terror anschläge seien aber eben auch
über mysteriöse vermisstenfälle fälle
die auch mich einfach nicht loslassen
mein name ist frank schneider
heute gehe ich mit ihnen auf spurensuche
nach menschen die einfach verschwunden
sind 8800 vermisste gibt es aktuell in
deutschland was ist mit ihnen passiert
wurden sie entführt sind sie freiwillig
untergetaucht weil sie ein neues leben
beginnen wollten oder wurden sie
möglicherweise sogar ermordet
heute bei eiskalt die größten
vermisstenfälle dieses blitzerfoto ist
das letzte lebenszeichen von niels
hansen wenig später findet die polizei
sei ein ausgebranntes auto hat er sich
etwa mit den falschen leuten eingelassen
beim wandern im schwarzwald verschwindet
die 26-jährige scarlett die letzte spur
führt zu einem parkplatz wo die die
studentin hier entführt wer hier alleine
wandert der ist tatsächlich auf sich
selbst gestellt und dennoch nahm ein
mantrailer hund hier an diesem findling
die letzte spur von scarlett auf und
markus schulze wird tot in der elbe
gefunden an seinem körper ein betonklotz
seine frau und seine tochter bleiben
verschwunden was ist familie schulze
zugestoßen ich hoffe tatsächlich dass
sie gefunden werden auf welche art auch
immer
heute unser erster fall im november 2013
verschwindet die 49 jährige heidi
dannhäuser ihr lebensgefährte sieht noch
wie sie abends ins bett geht doch am
nächsten morgen ist sie weg und sieht
auch bis heute nicht wieder auf ich
frage mich wie kann das sein eine frau
die mitten im leben steht einen job hat
ein lebensgefährten hat verschwindet
über nacht plötzlich und kommt nicht
wieder und ihr lebensgefährte war
währenddessen mit ihrem haus hat er
möglicherweise mit ihrem verschwinden
etwas zu tun
[Musik]
heidi dannhäuser
49 jahre alt von beruf postboten jeder
kennt sie jeder mag sie sie ist
zuverlässig immer pünktlich
[Musik]
in ihrer freizeit ist sie sehr aktiv
heidi joggt gerne in einem nahe
gelegenen wald oder macht touren mit
ihrem motorrad
sie lebt und arbeitet im nürnberger
stadtteil fischbach mit ihrem
lebensgefährten freddy hat sie dort ein
haus gekauft und in diesem haus wird
heidi zum letzten mal gesehen in der
nacht vom 13 auf den 14 november 2013
verliert sich ihre spur
heidi dannhäuser gilt seitdem als
vermisst die ermittler gehen von einem
verbrechen aus
[Musik]
egal was da vorgefallen ist
gut da draußen das hat sie nicht
verdient
die auch nicht drum werde nicht locker
lassen wir wollen nicht aufgeben weil
ich finde wir haben keine ruhe und
derjenige oder diejenigen die damit zu
tun haben welche was angetragen worden
ist sie sollen auch keine rolle
polizeipräsidien nürnberg seit acht
jahren laufen hier die fäden zum fall
heidi dannhäuser zusammen bild reporter
jörg völkerling ist mit
kriminalhauptkommissar thomas ringer
verabredet
dinge die sind ja sehr lange in der
ganzen materie schon seit dem ersten tag
und das sind nur die spurenakten in dem
fall das ist dass die spuren gehörten
film nachgegangen 130 schildert unter 30
sind es geworden ja aber leider bis
jetzt
was ist mit heidi dannhäuser geschehen
den abend des 13 11 20 13 konnte die
polizei anhand der aussagen des
lebensgefährten rekonstruieren freddy
will sich mit seinem pc beschäftigt
haben nach der arbeit kommt heidi nach
hause in die kellergasse in fischbach
die beiden unterhalten sich lautstark es
gibt meinungsverschiedenheiten
so berichten nachbarn heidi legt sich
aufs sofa freddy setzt sich wieder an
den computer erst spät in der nacht geht
er ins bett am nächsten morgen
donnerstag der vierzehnte elfte 2013 ist
heidi verschwunden so schildert ihr
lebensgefährte die letzten stunden er
hat sich auch erstmal nicht mehr so
viele gedanken gemacht sondern sich und
seine sachen gekümmert und ist dann aber
schon nervös geworden und hab es im wald
auf eigene faust nach ihr gesucht am 15
11 2013 hat er sich dann dazu bewegt
gefüllt anzeige zu erstatten weil sie
dann bis dahin auch nicht aufgetaucht
ist und auch ihre arbeitsstelle nicht
wahrgenommen hat dies ist uns sehr
zuverlässig antritt in diesem fall stand
auch zum beispiel noch ihr auto vor der
tür im schlafzimmer fehlt nichts und
ihre handtasche ist auch noch da darin
all ihre persönlichen sachen
personalausweis hausschlüssel
mobiltelefon
heidis schwester petra und stefanie
kommen sofort nach fischbach und hängen
zettel auf die damals 49 jährige heidi
zeigen und beschreiben
seit dem 14 11 20 13 10 vormittags wird
frau heidi dannhäuser vermisst sie ist 1
meter 64 groß hat blonde schulterlange
haare heidi geht fast täglich joggen ist
ihr im wald etwas passiert das wohnhaus
befindet sich in fischbach einem
ortsteil von nürnberg der lorenzer
reichswald ist ganz nah dort befindet
sich auch der eisweiher hatte heidi beim
laufen einen unfall ist sie unglücklich
in den weiher gestürzt oder wurde dort
ihr leichnam versteckt ermittler
befragen den lebensgefährten und alle
nachbarn während die
bereitschaftspolizei den nahe gelegenen
wald ab sucht ein spürhund hat dort
heidi dannhäuser vierter aufgenommen
[Musik]
taucher steigen an diesem kalten
novembertag sogar in den ice bayer
doch alle bemühungen führen ins leere
heidi dannhäuser bleibt verschwunden
sie waren den zeitpunkt noch mit freddie
zusammen aber da hat es gekriselt hat es
mich immer anrufen und hat ihr kummer
und ihre sorgen erzählen aber immer wenn
er natürlich nicht da war das hat er
immer heimlich gemacht welchen status
hat der lebensgefährte bei ihren
ermittlungen zu diesem zeitpunkt habe er
schuldete gegen freddy wurde damals
strafrechtlich wegen totschlags
ermittelt
wir hatten der lebensgefährte darauf
reagiert als sie an diesem morgen sehr
früh wahrscheinlich mit dem
durchsuchungsbeschluss in der hand bei
ihm auf der matte standen der
lebensgefährte hat hat das akzeptiert
mit beschluss aber er war natürlich
maximal überrascht ja ganz klar im mai
2018 rückt die polizei mit einem
großaufgebot hier in der kellergasse an
die ganze straße wird für den
durchgangsverkehr gesperrt gerade mal
der bus darf noch passieren drei tage
sind die ermittler im haus und stellen
es komplett auf den kopf überall wird
gründlich nachgeschaut mit
spezialgeräten nach hohlräumen geforscht
bei der suche nach skelettierten knochen
helfen speziell ausgebildete knochen
spürhunde die spezialisten rücken
erfolglos ab freddy kann nichts
nachgewiesen werden die ermittlungen
wegen totschlags werden eingestellt der
fall zum court case
visieren lag das auch an ihnen dass das
so ein fall sozusagen so loch sich
auftut und jemand daran verschwendet und
dass nicht klar ist nicht greifbar ist
für sie wie sehr macht ihnen das zu
schaffen also der fall heidi dannhäuser
ist wirklich ein fall der mir sehr zu
schaffen macht und ich werde solange ich
hier in dieser dienststelle diesen job
macht an diesem fall dranbleiben das
kann ich versichern weil ich mir das
auch als lebensaufgabe geschrieben haben
diesen fall zu klären
[Musik]
ein wirklich rätselhafter fall der
hoffentlich nach all den jahren doch
noch aufgeklärt werden kann
besonders tragisch empfinde ich
persönlich das schicksal das im juli
2015 ganz deutschland bewegte es ist der
fall der vermissten familie schulze aus
niedersachsen die eltern und auch die
tochter verschwinden über nacht doch
kurz darauf macht die polizei eine
grausame entdeckung
bilder die eine glückliche familie
zeigen die schulzes austrage marco und
silvia und ihr wunschkind die damals
zwölfjährige medien sie wird geliebt
besonders vater hat ein inniges
verhältnis zu ihr berichtet ihre
halbschwester sabine miriam ist ein
aufgewecktes fröhliches mädchen hat
viele freunde ihr großer traum sie
möchte einmal tierpflegerin werden
pferde sind ihre große leidenschaft am
liebsten geht sie reiten doch ihre
reiterferien wird sie nie antreten denn
miriam wird seit dem 23
juli 2015 vermisst genau wie ihre mutter
silvia bis heute beschäftigt ermittler
journalisten und angehörige vor allem
die eine frage leben mutter und tochter
noch irgendwo oder hat jemand die
gesamte familie ermordet hat gar der
vater frau und tochter getötet
es ist mittwoch der 22 juli 2015 ein tag
vor den sommerferien
wie schon die tage zuvor klagt miriam
auch an diesem morgen über
bauchschmerzen
ihre eltern beschließen deshalb dass
medien zu hause bleibt weil ihr vater an
diesem tag frei hat kümmert er sich um
seine kranke tochter
silvia schulze macht sich auf den weg
zur arbeit bei einem discounter nur
wenige kilometer von ihrem haus in drage
entfernt sie hat ihm gesagt er arbeitet
dort wohl einen anruf bekommen von ihrem
mann am nachmittag
möglicherweise mit dem inhalt dass ist
der tochter die an dem tag nicht in der
schule war also krankgemeldet war nicht
gut gehe deswegen sie vorzeitig die
arbeitsstelle verlassen hat und dann
nach hause gefahren ist um 16 und 20
verlässt silvia ihrer arbeit im elf
kilometer entfernten geesthacht um 16.50
verbindet sich ihr handy mit dem
heimischen wlan netzen trage danach gibt
es von silvia schulze kein lebenszeichen
keine nachweisbare spuren er gegen 17.25
telefoniert markus schulze noch zu hause
mit dem besitzer eines reiterhofs dem er
gelegentlich ausläuft er soll auch am
nächsten tag donnerstag arbeiten
doch marco schulze zögert berichtet der
mann später der polizei
was in die nächsten zwei stunden
geschieht konnte bis heute nicht
rekonstruiert werden um kurz nach 19 uhr
ruft miriam super an doch niemand geht
ans telefon
[Musik]
eine halbe stunde später um 19 30 ruft
markus schulze seinen schwiegervater
zurück erzählt dass es miriam und seiner
frau nicht gut geht sich beide schlafen
gelegt hätten doch was ist in den zwei
stunden zwischen diesen beiden festnetz
anrufen zwischen 17 25 und 19 uhr 30 mit
miriam und ihrer mutter geschehen was
ich tatsächlich am späten nachmittag bzw
durch die ganze nacht hindurch ereignet
hat müssen wir bis heute nicht es gibt
keine zeugen die den familienvater noch
am donnerstagmorgen
eine arme auto in drage wiederum gesehen
haben will wie er dort vorbei fuhr
danach verliert sich die spur als silvia
schulze am donnerstag und auch am
freitag nicht zur arbeit erscheint gehen
bei der polizei die ersten
vermisstenmeldungen 1 die beamten
durchsuchen das haus finden geldbörsen
handys und ausweise der familie auch
beide autos stehen vor dem haus
es deute nichts auf beispielsweise eine
auseinandersetzung hin ein kampf der da
stattgefunden haben könnte es deutet
nichts darauf hin dass die familie
möglicherweise verreist war und niemand
bescheid gesagt hat und das war eben
wenn der summe so dass die kollegen
gesagt haben hier ist mir passiert als
einfach nur ein spontaner wochenendtrip
es beginnt eine groß angelegte
suchaktion im ort und der näheren
umgebung wo ist familie schulze noch
geht die polizei von einem unglücksfall
aus auch bild chefreporter thomas knoop
ist von diesem zeitpunkt an mit dem fall
betraut als mann mit den nachbarn
gesprochen hat und die alle sagten die
familie gilt als super zuverlässig und
auf einmal ist sie weg da hatte man so
das erste mal das gespür da muss
irgendwas passiert so ein im fokus der
weiteren suchmaßnahmen der trucker
strand eine beliebte badestelle an der
elbe unweit des wohnhauses der familie
wir waren so nah boote im einsatz
taucher haben hier den bereich abgesucht
um die ganzen bogen köpfe herum immer in
der annahme möglicherweise weil dieser
ort doch irgendwo eine rolle spielte im
leben dieser familie seit mittlerweile
einer woche gilt familie schulze als
vermisst freitag der 31 juli 2015
lauenburg an der elbe rund 25 kilometer
von trage entfernt am frühen morgen
macht eine anwohnerin eine grausame
entdeckung
im seichten wasser der elbe nahe der
lauenburger altstadt treibt ein lebloser
menschlicher körper
kurze zeit nachdem diese nachricht bei
der polizei eingeht macht sich auch bild
chefreporter thomas knoop auf den weg
zum fundort der leiche
[Musik]
der mit land zogen und zogen sich über
stunden hin und erst kurz vor
mitternacht war dann klar der tote der
aus der elbe gezogen wurde war der
vermisste vater die umstände des
auffindens waren ja auch durchaus sehr
ungewöhnlich
beispielsweise war der leichnam mit
einem spanngurt
umwickelt an dem einen einen beton fuß
hin und
letztendlich konnten wir dann im zuge
der weiteren ermittlung feststellen dass
diese erkrankung von einer baustelle
genommen worden war
da mutter und tochter immer noch
vermisst werden gehen die ermittler
zunächst davon aus dass markus schulze
auch seine frau silvia und tochter
miriam getötet und in der elbe versenkt
hat
wir haben dann natürlich umfangreiche
suchmaßnahmen in der elbe an der brücke
unter wasser am wasser durchgeführt
dabei konnte ein fahrrad am grund der
elbe aufgefunden werden auf dem fahrrad
selber waren noch spanngurte gleicher
bauart wie sie auch am körper befestigt
waren zu finden und das fahrrad konnte
letztendlich auch der familie zugeordnet
werden noch am selben tag erfährt sabine
zenker am telefon vom tod ihres
stiefvaters
auch sechs jahre danach fällt es ihr
schwer über die tage und die
todesnachricht im sommer 2015 zu
sprechen der obduktionsbericht hat wohl
ergeben dass er bis zu sieben minuten
mit dem tod gekämpft haben muss sich
wirklich auf so eine art und weise das
leben zu nehmen zeigt für mich
eigentlich irgendwie davon dass er sich
dann auch für etwas bestrafen wollte
nach
hat marco schulze seine frau und seine
tochter getötet bevor er sich selbst das
leben genommen hat laut miriams
halbschwester soll es zwischen den
eheleuten zuletzt spannungen gegeben
haben wollte sich silvia schulze
möglicherweise von ihrem mann trennen
ich glaube man muss simpel denken
dass sie sich trennen wollte und das ja
eher das nicht akzeptieren wollte oder
konnte im august 2015 wenige wochen nach
dem verschwinden der familie die
vermeintliche wende im fall schulze bei
der polizei meldet sich eine zeugin
sie gibt an die familie noch am
nachmittag des 22
juli 2015 also am tag des verschwindens
am mühlenteich in holm seppensen circa
50 kilometer von trage entfernt gesehen
zu haben eine erste heiße spur
im zuge der überprüfung dort auch
tatsächlich
geruchsspuren durch höhere
fährtensuchhunde
anzeigen lassen können knie
übereinstimmt die fährte von vater
mutter und tochter angezeigt haben die
spuren von mutter und tochter endeten am
see und nur die spur des vaters wurde um
den see herum bis zur straße zurück
angezeigt für uns ein deutliches indiz
dass dieser ort leben eine rolle
gespielt haben muss
die zeugen will einen streit mitbekommen
haben später schreie und einen knall
bild chefreporter thomas knoop erinnert
sich an die tage der suche am sep in
mühlen teich
der see ist fünf meter tief und man hat
mehrere punkte markiert 17 insgesamt so
nabu ausfindig gemacht worden bei jedem
punkt dachte man jetzt passiert was
jetzt kommt eine entdeckung es passiert
am ende nicht die hunde vierten lassen
vermuten dass markus schulze seine frau
und sein kind hier am see getötet hat
letztendlich ist dass das was für alle
seiten total frustrierend und
nervenaufreibend ist dass wir so wenig
wissen über den konkreten ablauf und das
wir vor allen dingen
das definitiven ende nämlich das
auffinden von mutter und tochter nicht
haben so dass das immer noch
ungeklärt ist ich hoffe tatsächlich dass
sie gefunden werden auf welche art auch
in mainz wird mir klarheit bringen und
klarheit ist heilung irgendwann und
heilung bedeutet für mich dass ich
abschließen kann
endlich klarheit wünschen sich auch
freunde und familie der vermissten
skelett die erfahrene wanderin bricht zu
einer großen tour durch den schwarzwald
auf doch die 26 jährige studentin und
ihr auffällig roter wanderrucksack
kennen nie wieder zurück ihre letzte
spur stellt die polizei vor ein großes
rätsel wurde sie verschleppt oder ist
sie abgestürzt
kann hier ein mensch einfach
verschwinden spurlos
[Musik]
jens kahl etwa am tag ihres
verschwindens 26 jahre alt sie hatte
blonde haare
sie trug einen großen roten rucksack an
dem eine isomatte und hier ein buntes
detail auch ein rotes herz so eine art
anhänger befestigt waren sie trug
wanderstiefel und auch eine wanderschaft
wo ist gar nicht sie wollte eins sein
mit sich und der natur und verschwand in
den tiefen des schwarzwaldes
irgendwo da draußen sein bitte bitte
bitte melde dich deine eltern möchten so
gerne gewissheit haben und machen sich
schreckliche sorgen um dich
es ist der zehnte september 2020 seit
sechs tagen ist studentin skelett aus
bad lippspringe auf dem berühmten
schluchtensteig unterwegs 120 kilometer
ist diese anspruchsvolle wanderweg lang
skala des top ausgerüstet eine erfahrene
wanderin auf der sechsten etappe
zwischen todtmoos und wehr verliert sich
ihre spur an dieser hütte startet ihre
etappe an diesem zehnten september die
letzte nacht vor ihrem verschwinden
verbrachte scarlett es hier in der
kirche berghütte beitritt muss für
gerade mal 28 euro hatte sie hier ein
recht günstiges nachtquartier gefunden
gegen 9 uhr 30 gingen sie hinüber ins
hotel rössle begleicht die rechnung
wobei eine überwachungskamera sie dabei
einfingen wie sie mit dem hotelchef noch
ein paar worte wechselte danach gingen
sie mit ihrem markanten roten rucksack
über den parkplatz richtung todtmoos wo
sie gegen 10 uhr 4 am edeka-markt
eintragen
elf minuten bis 10 uhr 15 verbracht das
geld an jedem septembermorgen hier im
schmidt's markt in todtmoos das ergab
später die auswertung ihres handys sie
kaufte sich ein smoothie und etwas beim
bäcker die aufnahmen der
überwachungskamera sind die letzten
bilder von scarlett mit denen die
polizei in waldshut tiengen seit nunmehr
einem jahr nach der jungen frau fahndet
tagelang suchten feuerwehr bergwacht und
polizei das gebiet an der deutsch
schweizerischen grenze aber ergebnislos
reporter jörg völkerling tracking guide
björn könig um sich selbst ein bild von
der lage vor ort zu machen handyempfang
ist teilweise sehr schlecht bis gar
nicht vorhanden
gerade in der größeren schlucht die
weiter unten kommend richtung wer das
teilweise gar kein handyempfang die ist
wirklich richtig steil und mit sehr
ausgesetzten stellen da
hat man schlechte karten wenn man da
unter rückt auch die hälfe der familie
gebe die hoffnung nicht auf verteilen
suchplakate in jeder der fünf schluchten
befinden uns auf einem parkplatz entlang
der landstraße 148 etwa sieben kilometer
außerhalb von todtmoos die gibt es
keinerlei handyempfang links und rechts
der straße steigen tief und dunkel die
wälder hervor wer hier alleine wandert
der ist tatsächlich auf sich selbst
gestellt und dennoch nahm ein mantrailer
hund hier an diesen findlingen die
letzte spur von scarlett auf wir hatten
auch nicht damit gerechnet dass es so
eine konkrete spur noch gibt ein jahr
später die kameraden die damit bei der
suchaktion noch mal dabei waren die die
die ware selber erstaunt wie wie das
noch die hunde wirklich noch alle
einheitlich denselben punkt gefunden
haben für uns nur auch wieder
unerklärlich warum dort genau die
sportler wie
abgeschnitten ist
600 km weiter nördlich bad lippspringe
bei paderborn hier war scarlett zu hause
hier ist sie groß geworden von hier
zieht zu ihren reisen um die welt
aufgebrochen
bild reporter sebastian bringe begibt
sich auf spurensuche in scarletts
nordrhein westfälische heimat aber wer
war eigentlich galt es wir wissen dass
sie eine weltenbummlerin gewesen ist das
zeigen bilder auf ihrem facebook profil
sie liebt es zu reisen sie war mit dem
rucksack in asien in thailand in myanmar
in malaysia aber auch in russland und
auf den malediven und ausgerechnet im
schwarzwald verschwindet sie plötzlich
spurlos
was ist scarlett passiert wurde sie
entführt oder ist sie abgestürzt
inzwischen wurde eine anzeige erstattet
mit hinweisen auf ein tötungsdelikt
es ist tatsächlich eine anzeige
erstattet worden wegen eines
gewaltverbrechens diese anzeige ist muss
ich sagen relativ hemdsärmlig und
spekulativ nennt keine belastbaren
beweismittel für einen solchen vorwurf
wir haben um diese anzeige zu genügen
tatsächlich förmlich ein
todesermittlungsverfahren
eingeleitet wir haben aber bis dahin das
muss auch ganz klar betont werden
überhaupt gar keine hinweise auf ein
gewaltverbrechen
unfall straftat die neue spur der
suchhunde lässt die ermittlungen jetzt
wieder aufleben skaletz eltern offen so
sehr weiter auf ein lebenszeichen ihrer
tochter
in die polizei in so einem
vermisstenfall vorgeht darüber möchte
ich jetzt mit ulrich bux sprechen ulrich
bux war 45 jahre lang polizist zuletzt
erster kriminalhauptkommissar und 30
jahre bei der mordkommission herr books
wie geht die polizei vor wenn eine
person verschwindet er grundsätzlich ist
also ein vermisstenfall immer
individuell man muss immer die einzelnen
umstände prüfen bei senioren bei kindern
ist es immer alles verschieden gibt es
anhaltspunkte dafür dass die person x
nicht freiwillig ihren lebensbereich
verlassen hat muss man natürlich auch
gucken anhaltspunkte für den
krankheitsfall dann würden wir was
machen ansonsten darf auch jeder mensch
mal weg sein auch ohne seine verwandten
benachrichtigen zu müssen ja ansonsten
prüft mir die gesamten umstände
lebensbereich konto bewegungen führt die
person handy mit kann man das notfalls
orten gibt es irgendwelche
auffälligkeiten im allgemeinen verhalten
am arbeitsplatz gegenüber freunden
nachbarn ja und gibt es dann hinweise wo
sich die person aufhalten könnte werden
dieser ort überprüft jetzt ist ja hier
in dem fall so das scala in einem
waldgebiet verschwunden ist ist wurden
mantrailer hunde eingesetzt wie muss man
sich vorstellen wie agiert man da und
wie sicher ist das was bringt den
ermittlern so ein einsatz gut man muss
immer gucken ist die personen jetzt das
erste mal in diesem bereich oder es ist
ein gewohnter bereich dann sie die
mantrailer natürlich ein bisschen
fragwürdig zu betrachten weil wenn eine
person jeden tag eine gleiche strecke
läuft der und verfolgt immer die frische
spur aber die können da durchaus vom
vortag schon mal die frisches zu sein
und insofern in diesem fall war es ja so
dass sie in diesem wald noch nicht wahr
ist das eigentlich ein gutes indiz wobei
man muss sich das vorstellen wir
verlieren ja natürlich haut shop und
durch unsere bewegung aber der hund
läuft hier nicht genau die selbe strecke
sondern es gibt verwirrung
witterungseinflüsse anderer art und das
erstaunlichste ist
sollte die person allerdings verstorben
sein gibt es ein problem weil diese
mantrailer hunde ein sogenanntes leichen
beide verhalten haben das heißt die
zeichen nicht unbedingt an die würden
auch teilweise an der toten person
vorbei laufen das ist also immer sehr
zwiespältig wie herr geht man da das
kann am besten nur der hunde fördern
entscheiden jetzt ist gar nicht seit
über zwei jahren verschwunden was sagt
ihre berufserfahrung tauchen menschen
nach so langer zeit wirklich noch lebend
wieder auf ja durchaus also es gibt
genug fälle pro person nach vielen
jahren wieder auftauchen ein ganz
krasser fall war ja mal eine person die
nach 31 jahren oder anderen personalien
aber nicht strafrechtlich relevant
wieder in einer ganz entfernten stadt
auftauchte sie hatte auch kein interesse
daran dass jemand überhaupt weiß wo sie
ist und sie kam auch ohne ihren wegen
staatlichen unterstützung wunderbar
zurecht ja herr box vielen dank bis
hierhin wir sprechen gleich nochmal ja
dass ihre tochter lebend wieder
auftaucht das hofft auch erika schneider
aus essen ihre tochter bianca blumige
verschwand vor 21 jahren und bis heute
gibt es keine wirklich konkrete spur was
mit ihr passiert sein könnte sie
verschwand obwohl sie ein kleines baby
hatte meine kollegin katrin weuster
verfolgt diesen fall von anfang an sie
kann uns sagen wie der stand der
ermittlungen ist
jeden tag blickt erika schneider in
essen von ihrem balkon auf die wohnung
aus der ihre tochter bianca vor 21
jahren verschwand
das ist natürlich ganz schwer wenn
geburtstage sind oder hochzeiten ich
natürlich mit bianca nicht mehr erleben
kann
bianca hat eine glückliche kindheit und
weiß schon als teenager in dass sie früh
mutter werden möchte mit 18 jahren lernt
sie erkennen im januar 2000 bringt sie
ihren gemeinsamen sohn zur welt doch der
lernt seine mutter nie kennen wächst bei
einer pflegefamilie auf denn am 6 august
2000 verschwindet bianca bis heute
spurlos hat vaters wenn etwas damit zu
tun
seit biancas verschwinden berichtet bild
reporterin katrin weuster immer wieder
über den fall
süßer fratz hoffentlich ist deine mama
einfach nur weg gelaufen bianca stritt
mit ihrem freund dann war sie weg
bianka boyke vor zwölf jahren spurlos
verschwunden
als über diesem ersten termin bei den
eltern waren hat auch der ex freund der
vermissten noch vehement mit gesucht hat
sich mit flugblättern fotografieren
lassen das hat sich dann geändert als er
zwischenzeitlich in den wochen und
monaten danach von der polizei auch als
verdächtiger geführt wurde was ist mit
bianca passiert ist sie weg gelaufen
oder wurde sie opfer eines verbrechens
essen vogelheim fünf kilometer nördlich
der city in diesem mehrfamilienhaus
wohnt bianca blumige im jahr 2000 mit
ihrem sohn bis zu dem tag an dem sie
verschwindet von sven l ist sie frisch
getrennt
ich würde mal so abschätzen dass sie so
anderthalb jahre bis zwei jahre zusammen
war wobei sie ja im dezember 990 schon
ausgezogen ist war der jenem bauch
getreten hat wir so hochschwanger war
unweit des fußballstadions von rot weiss
essen betreibt erika im august 2000 eine
kneipe wo ihr die anker am 58 bis fünf
uhr morgens aushilft sie lernt einen
jungen mann kennen mit dem sie das lokal
verlässt dort sieht erika ihre tochter
zum letzten mal
am nächsten morgen werden die janka und
ihr ex freund sven elf von nachbarn
gesehen wie sie zusammen in die wohnung
gehen es kommt wieder zum streit etwa
aus eifersucht am nachmittag telefoniert
eric hat zum letzten mal mit ihrer
tochter
ja ich hab da noch mal mit ihr so gegen
14 45 telefoniert
ich sagte ihm jetzt ja braucht gar nicht
mehr wiederkommen ich will gar nicht
mehr sehen ich gehe jetzt in der wanne
eine stunde später versucht erika ihre
tochter erneut zu erreichen aber sven
geht ans telefon immer wieder ruft erika
an jedes mal hört sie etwas anderes
warum geht man kann nicht ans telefon
das war sehr untypisch aber das ist mir
in dem moment gar nicht aufgefallen weil
er mir sagt ja sie sind wanne oder
sie ist mein kind beschäftigt oder sie
ist alle boote zigaretten holen
vom gefühl her sage ich so wenn ich im
nachhinein wenn ich mein spiel kam mir
das schon komisch vor aber mein kopf
holz nicht realisieren meine mutter ist
an den sonntag gegen amt bist du dann
rüber im biancas wohnung und weil er da
gab's da man ja an dem wochenende ab
sondern gespült und hat auch das
badezimmer ein bisschen saubergemacht
und meine mutter hat am blut in der
wanne gefunden und hat sich aber gedacht
der ire regel gab unterhalt nicht
weggemacht eine mögliche spur wird
vernichtet war es menstruationsblut oder
blut einer verletzung
und meine mutter sagte er hat sich auf
fensterbank hat er gesessen hat auf die
straße schaut und hat immer gesagt jetzt
ist schon wieder hier vorbeigefahren die
bank hat aber weder führerscheine auto
also alles sehr mysteriös um 23 uhr ruft
erika das letzte mal an wieder behauptet
wenn bianca sei nicht nach hause
gekommen als erika in die wohnung kommt
findet sie aber geldbeutel schlüssel und
handy der verschwundenen nur ihr ausweis
fehlt 24 stunden später startet erika
nun eine suchaktion doch bianca bleibt
verschwunden nach vier tagen suche gibt
erika eine vermisstenanzeige auf ihr
eindruck die polizei handelt zu
zögerlich wenn dann zu vermisstenstelle
hinwollten vermisstenanzeige aufgegeben
und die dame hat mich dann aber
regelrecht ausgelacht und hat gesagt so
anstellen 19-jährige verschwindet junge
also wenn man ich kenne mein kind und
ist dann auch unter auch unter zwang
sind sie dann mit mir im biancas wohnung
gegangen doch die durchsuchung der
wohnung bleibt ergebnislos und ist
wochen später berichten nachbarn
gegenüber erikas mutter von einem
heftigen streit über den nachbarn die
haben auch und knall gehört und dann war
ruhe haben aber ganz lange zeit nichts
gesagt das ist dann erst durch zufall
rausgekommen was ich dann später bei der
polizei angegeben habe und die wurden
dann wohl auch verhört das denn wissen
excuse ermittler bei der polizei essen
er rollt den fall bianca blömecke wieder
auf seine vorgänger errichten erst ende
oktober 2000 die von erika gewünschte
mordkommission zu spät zwei monate nach
dem verschwinden von bianca da wo die
mordkommission eingerichtet und dann
sind auch durchsuchungsaktion gestartet
und auch die wohnung bot sich angeschaut
dann wurden sie die die maßnahmen die
man die halt mit einer mordkommission
einhergehen würden dann getroffen
hat sven seiner ex freundin bianca etwas
angetan die polizei handy ab und sucht
nach möglichen leichen ab lagerorten
am zweiten mai 2001 amtes aufgrund der
aussage der nachbarn zur festnahme von
bianca ex freund sven t er gilt als
hauptverdächtiger und wird bei der
polizei vernommen doch die beweise gegen
den reichen nicht aus er kommt
schließlich auf freien fuß
totschlag verjährt nach 20 jahren daher
könnten mögliche mitwisser heute eine
auskunft geben ohne strafrechtlich
verfolgt zu werden darauf hofft der
ermittler
vielleicht hat sich auch der täter einen
anderen menschen gegenüber offenbart und
die person die suchen wir also die
mitwisser die hinweise geben könnten was
mir damals geschehen
er wog sie waren ja 30 jahre leiter der
mordkommission in münster sie haben eine
große erfahrung was kann man bei so
einem fall nach 21 jahren noch machen
bzw was müsste passieren damit die
polizei noch mal die chance hat diesen
fall aufzuklären
ja gut es gibt ja durchaus auch mal die
möglichkeit ist mit erhellenden
zeugenaufruf zu versuchen es gibt ja
auch wirklich personen die nach vielen
jahren sich plötzlich doch erinnern und
sich dann aufgrund eines solchen
aufrufen endlich aufraffen sich bei uns
zu melden
ansonsten kann man nur noch schauen gibt
es spurenmaterial von damals dass ich
vielleicht mit neueren
wissenschaftlichen untersuchungsmethoden
untersuchen lassen kann ich denke da zum
beispiel an die dna technik die sich als
sehr weit entwickelt hat das wäre so
eine möglichkeit nach so vielen jahren
noch mal was zu versuchen gibt es denn
manchmal auch mitwisser man hört ja
immer wieder dass sich täter
möglicherweise auch jemand an vertrauen
der dann aber auch dass nämlich kein
großes gewicht beimisst und deshalb
nicht zur polizei geht ist das denn auch
eine chance dass es menschen gibt die
etwas wissen selber an der tag gar nicht
beteiligt waren diese chancen und diese
fälle gibt es tatsächlich aber es ist
eben halt das problem wie erreiche ich
diese person wie sie in sozial zündung
um diese person endlich wach zu kriegen
jetzt sind solche fälle ja auch für die
ermittler schwierig werde neben dem
beitrag auch mal gehört dass ermittler
so etwas mit nach hause nehmen wie war
das bei ihnen selbst und nackt so etwas
auch an einem ermittler man möchte den
fall ja auch klären möchte den angehören
ja auch gewissheit verschaffen ja
selbstverständlich sagt ein fall
aber das problem ist ja nicht hier
ermittler sondern grundsätzlich ist ja
so dass wir immer das bestreben haben
die tat aufzuklären um auch den
angehörigen gerecht zu werden denn das
sind auch opfer und insofern nimmt man
jeden fall natürlich mit nach hause auch
jetzt zum beispiel nach meiner
pensionierung habe ich auch noch kontakt
zu opferfamilien es ist die ungewissheit
bei den vermisstenfällen die besonders
vermögend ist dass man gar nicht weiß
was passiert ist genau das problem ist
wenn ich eine person später einmal tot
auffinden dann tritt schon bei den
angehörigen eine deutliche erleichterung
ein obwohl die gesamtumstände ja auch
nicht so schön sind aber sie haben dann
endlich die gewissheit was mit ihrem
anhören passiert ist vielen dank herr
box für diese wirklich spannenden
einblick in den polizeialltag ja in dem
nächsten fall geht es auch wieder um
eine junge frau die vermisst wird melina
ist verschwunden die feiert noch mit
freunden parkt sie verschickt sogar noch
fröhlich fotos von ihrem handy die sie
in diesem park macht dann geht sie
angeblich nach hause und sie
verschwindet eltern freunde alle fragen
sich auch die ermittler was kann dieser
jungen frau nur passiert sein
darf ich mich einmal vorstellen bin 21
jahre alt komme aus kasachstan wohne in
der nähe von berlin
seit dem 25
september ist melina spurlos
verschwunden
aber
einfach verschwunden doch inzwischen
ermittelt die staatsanwaltschaft potsdam
in einem tötungsdelikt gegen unbekannt
es gibt keinen hinweis darauf dass die
junge frau den mute park zu fuß mit
einem taxi oder einem öffentlichen
verkehrsmittel verlassen hat
zuletzt gesehen wird melina hier im jute
park in luckenwalde mit freunden feiert
und trinkt sie danach verliert sich ihre
spur ihr letztes lebenszeichen entsteht
hier auf dieser bank
um 1 uhr morgens soll melina den park
verlassen und nach hause gegangen sein
ihre wohnung liegt nur zwei kilometer
vom nuthe park entfernt doch dort kommt
sie nie an
freunde und familie starten einen
vermissten aufruf bei social media die
anteilnahme ist groß die polizei nimmt
die ermittlungen auf sucht den park nach
hinweisen ab auch ein kleiner bach die
nuthe wird abgetaucht ergebnislos das
mädchen bleibt verschwunden die
ermittler gehen zunächst jedoch nicht
von einem verbrechen aus milena sei von
zu hause abgehauen melina familie stammt
aus der ehemaligen sowjetunion wie lina
geht im brandenburgischen luckenwalde
zur schule machte eine ausbildung zur
bürokauffrau auf social media zeigt sich
die 22-jährige als selbstbewusste junge
frau gibt sich freizügig und den
partylaune eine scheinwelt im wahren
leben beschreibt uns ihre
arbeitskollegin die junge frau ist eine
völlig andere person
melina von zwei seiten immer der
schüchterne mädchen und einmal so wie
sie sich bei instagram präsentiert wo
man denkt es ist eine wirklich
selbstbewusste frau aber ich denke das
was äußerlich alles so erscheinen das
ist halt mehr fasst aber innerlich ist
ein wirklich sehr schüchternes mädchen
sehr sehr fleißiger
zuverlässig pünktlich
und jetzt kann sie einfach nicht mehr
und das passt einfach nicht zu ihr
zuerst heißt es media sei auf dem weg
nach hause verschwunden
doch jetzt sagt die staatsanwaltschaft
es gebe keinerlei hinweise dass
milliardär park überhaupt verlassen hat
was ist in der nacht zum 25 september
hier im jute park in luckenwalde mit der
22 jährigen berliner passiert
wir lernen eine freundin von melina über
instagram kennen kannst du uns erzählen
was an dem abend passiert ist sie hat
drei kumpels getroffen und mit ihnen
getrunken sie hatten wir zuletzt um 0 11
ein video geschickt die drei jungs haben
getanzt sie saß auf der bank und dann
dann war sie gegen 1 uhr nachts auf dem
weg nach hause ein kumpel wollte sie
nach hause fahren aber sie wollte nicht
da er betrunken war was glaubst du ist
wenn dir passiert sie würde nicht
einfach abhauen sie wollte sich am
nächsten tag mit mir treffen hast du
irgendeine theorie was passiert sein
könnte
wahrscheinlich wurde sie entführt
wir treffen die jungs mit den melina in
der nacht ihres verschwindens zusammen
war die letzten zeugen die melina leben
ziehen einer der jungen männer ist lenas
ex freund nach ihrer trennung finden sie
wieder zueinander
er sagt sie seien inzwischen gute
freunde filmen lassen wollen sie sich
nicht aber auch sie behaupten melina sei
um ein uhr morgens alleine nach hause
gegangen ein klarer widerspruch zu den
aussagen der staatsanwaltschaft von der
bank an der melina den abend verbringt
und sich von ihren freunden
verabschiedet haben soll ist ihr weg
leicht zu beobachten etwas verdächtiges
will aber niemand gesehen haben der fall
melina hinterlässt viele fragen
sie braucht uns
und auch im nächsten fall bleiben bis
heute viele fragen offen ein mann
verschwindet von einem campingplatz in
der nähe von hamburg nur wenige tage
später entdeckte ein autofahrer auf
einem einsamen parkplatz den lichterloh
brennenden audi des vermissten alle
spuren sind zerstört und zeugen auch
ermittler bringen weitere mysteriöse
details ans tageslicht
ein blitzerfoto als letztes
lebenszeichen von niels hansen hat er
sich mit kriminellen eingelassen wurde
er beseitigt dieser fall birgt viele
rätsel für die staatsanwaltschaft ist
bislang klar
also nach unseren ermittlungen ist niels
hansen am 20 oktober im letzten jahr
verschwunden
zuletzt hat er sich offenbar auf einem
campingplatz blaue lagune in güster
aufgehalten das sind unsere erkenntnisse
die noch gesichert sind danach verliert
sich seine spur wir begeben uns auf
spurensuche am campingplatz wo nils
hansen zuletzt gesehen worden war ist
hier etwas mit dem geschehen wurde er
opfer eines verbrechens wir sprechen mit
campingplatz bewohnern und fragen nach
dem vermissten
hier am idyllisch gelegene campingplatz
blaue lagune in güster an der
landesgrenze zwischen schleswig holstein
und mecklenburg vorpommern verliert sich
am 20 oktober 2020 die spur von niels
hansen etwa eine stunde hat der
barbetreiber aus neu wulmstorf bei
hamburg hierher zu fahren doch am 21
oktober lockt sich sein handy zum
letzten mal ins netz ein zwei monate
danach schickt die mordkommission aus
lübeck starke kräfte hier auf eine
partielle lässt die parzelle umgraben
und schickt taucher in den see doch
ergebnislos
sechsundzwanzigster oktober um 1 45 geht
ein notruf bei der feuerwehr geesthacht
ein zeuge meldet ein brennendes fahrzeug
vom parkplatz am pumpspeicherwerk kurz
darauf wird klar es ist der audi q5 des
vermissten niels hansen nun fragt sich
die kripo steckte niels hansen sein
fahrzeug selbst in brand um danach
unterzutauchen oder hat ein potenzieller
täter das fahrzeug angezündet um damit
dna spuren zu verwischen
als wir eintrafen fanden wir einen pkw
abgestellt auf einem parkplatz vor der
pkw stand bereits im vollbrand zunächst
einmal haben wir kontrolliert ob
eventuell noch insassen im pkw waren das
war zum glück nicht der fall die
erfahrung zeigt auch in der
vergangenheit dass es oftmals geklaute
pkws sind die dann am ende der tour
angezündet werden waren die zinsen in
kriminelle machenschaften verwickelt
nach weiteren recherchen lässt sich
unser reporter sicher irgendetwas
scheint hier nicht zustimmen seit
nunmehr einem jahr ermittelt die polizei
in lübeck in der vermisstensache niels
hansen doch mit jedem tag wird seinem
verschwinden mysteriöser am anfang
kostete seine familie noch verzweifelte
suche aufrufe bei facebook doch
inzwischen ist sie komplett verstummt
auch wir haben versucht mit seiner ex
frau und seiner kleinen schwester und
kontakt zu kommen doch vergeblich
stattdessen erfuhren wir von kriminellen
vorleben von niels hansen von vorstrafen
wegen autodiebstählen von haft antreten
die er dann bei facebook als urlaube
verkaufte wir konnten auch mit einem ex
knacki sprechen der vor der kamera nicht
reden wollte der uns aber wirklich sagte
nils ist ein verräter er ist dann die
falschen leute geraten jetzt hat er
bekommen was er verdient hat
und das ist nicht alles von einer guten
bekannten erfahren wir zunächst von
hansens verbindungen ins rotlicht
gewerbe
denn abends wieder mit zurück genommen
das straßenstrich und
die miete für ihn
und dann rutscht dir auf einmal raus
[Musik]
irgendwann haben
und drei optionen mehr konnte ich nicht
mehr populär
und sie ist nicht die einzige in hansens
heimatort sprechen wir mit den besitzern
einer autowerkstatt auch diese beiden
wollen den vermissten kürzlich gesehen
haben
[Musik]
auch
der vermisstenfall bleibt spannend die
polizei lübeck sucht dringend weitere
zeugen die ihn oder sein auto nach dem
21 september 2020 gesehen haben wir
würden natürlich nach wie vor auch heute
noch gerne wissen während nils hansen
und im bereich des zeitlichen im bereich
münster und am 20 oktober
beziehungsweise zuvor oder auch danach
noch gesehen hat und natürlich
interessiert uns auch der möglicherweise
das fahrzeug von herrn hansen das ist
eben ein dunkler audi s5 mit auch
dunklen felgen in der zeit bis zum 26
oktober noch gesehen hat
wenn sie in diesem oder einem anderen
der mysteriösen vermisstenfälle hinweise
geben können dann rufen sie bitte die
polizei das war eiskalt die größten
kriminalfälle vielen dank fürs zuschauen
bleiben sie uns treu und bis zum
nächsten mal
[Musik]